I think of human flourishing as living well.
Maybe a question we've all asked is: What
is the good life?
What does it mean to live well?
And that's a question that philosophers as
well as people like you and me have asked
over the centuries, right?
Aristotle had an interesting answer to that
question.
Aristotle would say that people flourish when
they exercise virtue.
And virtues are things like wisdom and courage.
So if you think of a virtue like courage,
then flourishing — it happens when you exercise
courage even in the most difficult circumstances.
So it's possible to flourish even if you are
going through something really hard.
I would say mathematics is actually a vehicle
for helping people flourish.
If you think about what it means to do mathematics,
part of what you're trying to do in mathematics
is seek truth.
In seeking truth you build in abilities — virtues
— of rigorous thinking, handling ideas well,
being intellectually honest.
If you think about what it means to play with
a puzzle or work with a math problem, you're
building in perseverance, which is helping
you solve the next problem even if you don't
end up solving this problem.
So mathematics, I would say, helps people
flourish.